j'y ai consacré à la création tuer
michel philosophe 1 sur un philosophe
des sciences
tu t'occupes dans deux de savoir comment
se console
comment se fabriquent les sciences et la
pensée scientifique qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire la création scientifique
on peut dire d'abord que on ne dit
jamais création création scientifique en
veux pas oh c'est très rare ou très
anciens très archaïque on dit
communément que quelqu'un a inventé un
théorème ou que une équipe ou un
laboratoire vient de faire une
découverte
on parle d' inventions et en parle de
découverte annoncée pas la même chose
l'an
ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
en effet le mot découverte signifie
quelque chose de cannes au brésil oui
c'est ça comme un marin qui prenant
telle et telle route inconnu découvre
une terre où personne n'a jamais mis les
pieds comme monde ans il existait déjà
ce pays existaient déjà et le navigateur
l'a découvert et effectivement lorsqu'on
dit découvertes scientifiques cela qu'on
note que la vérité était déjà la wii est
qu on la découvrait alors qu'elle
n'était pas vu dans le monde physique
part également de physique par exemple
tandis que quand on dit invention on
veut dire que cette idée où ce type de
théorèmes cédera a été construit ou par
l'inventeur ou par le groupe qui est à
l'invention c'est à dire qu'il ne
préexiste est pas à l'acte de le
construire
alors ça fait une sorte de différence
presque philosophique entre les deux
mais pratiquement pratiquement on prend
l'un pour l'autre et l'autre pour
l'heure en fait dire découverte ça veut
dire connaît réaliste et dire invention
ça voudrait dire peut-être côté
idéaliste à toi tu te sens plutôt
réaliste plutôt idées à dinan je crois
que dès qu'il y a des mots en isme il ya
des groupes qui croit il ya un groupe
qui est pour et un contre un contre une
population qui croît une population qui
déteste cette école c'est la guerre et
par conséquent c'est la guerre par
conséquent
d'invention je crois que parce que quand
il ya la guerre il ya pas d'invention
n'y a pas d'intention
je tiens beaucoup à cette idée l'idée
suivante c'est que lorsqu'on lorsqu'on a
une opinion ou lorsqu'on a une croyance
contrairement à ce qu'on croit l'opinion
est la croyance ne sont pas libres au
sens au sens qu'on peut aller dans
n'importe quelle direction dans une
surface
on n'a pas de degrés de liberté l'invs
en cela la croyance et l'opinion sont
des choses stable des choses serré sur
soi est complètement
par quoi immobile par les habitudes par
la manière de penser du groupe ainsi de
suite
l'opinion est stable la croyance est
immobile et au contraire la science est
complètement libre contrairement à ce
qu'on pense c'est la croyance qui est
immobile est la science qui est mobile
ou volubile c'est la croyance et
l'opinion qui sont arrêtés tandis que la
science peut évoluer de façon
complètement la bible
j'ai envie de dire presque conscience on
peut penser n'importe quoi tandis que
dans les opinions qu'elles soient
politiques ou les croyances ou même
philosophie qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure
du réalisme et de lidl
je crois qu'on ne peut plus inventer
parce qu'on est bloqué parce que le au
xviie siècle ont appelé l'opiniâtreté
avoir une opinion c'est à trop pignate
re être scientifique c'est se livrer à
la totale liberté de penser les prix
quand même dans le dans le mouvement oui
ces scientifiques comme c'est ça c'est à
dire qu'un couloir quand c'est ça on est
pris par des contraintes
c'est à dire il ya des contraintes de
rigueur des contraintes d'exactitude
mais ce ne sont pas des contraintes
différentes de la syntaxe lorsque je
parle et je suis bien contraint par la
part la langue française et c'est une
contrainte qui me gêne pas tellement à
l'intérieur de sa j'invente à
l'intérieur des contraintes d'exactitude
de rigueur etc toutes les contraintes
ordinaire des sciences à partir de là la
science c'est l'invention c'est la
découverte c'est à dire la totale
liberté de penser n'importe quoi à
l'intérieur de ces contraintes il ya
d'autres types de contraintes que
subtile non je veux dire ce qu'on
appelle le mouvement des idées par
exemple ça existe aussi en cela existe
gars je parle pas de la mode va tout à
fait de la mode mais l'atmosphère du
temps c'est existent n'ont aucun doute
un certain genre de choses est un moment
avec ça alors on va dire qu'il ya deux
sortes d'inventions de sang découvertes
la découverte ou l'invention qui se fait
dans l'esprit du temps qui se fait dans
la mode du temps qui se fait dans l'air
du temps
ça c'est une invention on ne pouvait
prévoir étant donné l'air du temps c'est
pas ça la grande invention et les normes
invention la grande découverte c'est
celle qui sort de l'air du temps
inventer s'est trouvée d'un nouveau et
donc il fait scandale et donc qui
généralement n'est pas perçue ou qui est
mal perçue il ya la petite invention
dans la mode et la grande invention qui
bouleverse qui bouleverse une histoire
qui bouleverse l'air du temps qui
bouleverse ce que tu as appelé tout à
l'heure le mouvement des idées
par conséquent la lhomme qui inventent
doit vivre le moins possible dans l'air
temps s'il veut inventer s'il veut
découvrir contrairement à ce qu'on croit
il ya une morale de l'invention
il ya une vie du scientifique qui désire
consacrer sa vie à inventer une morale
au sens style de vivre sans façons de
livres une façon de vivre
on peut le dire de façon tout à fait
simple l'homme qui se consacre à ce
genre d'activités il doit manger avec
cette activité couché avec cette
activité boire avec cette activité de
faire que ça ne faire que ça on demande
à newton comment avez vous découvert la
gravitation universelle réponse annie
pensant toujours qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'entre le drap du
sud radio entre le plafond et le
plancher entre les murs entre la poire
et le fromage
il y penser toujours je pense que l'avis
scientifique et c'est son bonheur est
une vie complètement unitaire elle est
vouée complètement voué à celui décrit
un univers très austère mais c'est une
morale de l'austérité ça non je crois
pas je crois ne faire qu'une chose
toujours on ne fait pas qu'une chose
cette chose on peut ruser avec sa
présence c'est à dire que rencontrer des
amis aller à la pêche se baigner
peut-être une chose qu'on fait comme
tout le monde mais il n'empêche qu'à
l'intérieur de soi même la petite aux
roues est toujours en train de tourner
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas vraiment à
la pêche on est vraiment au billard on
est vraiment partout c'est à dire voilà
comment avez vous inventez la
gravitation universelle
réponse en y pensant toujours non
réponse en regardant tomber des pommes
mais tout le monde à revers des tombes
et des pommes et par conséquent newton
se promener dans la campagne seulement
il a vu l'exceptionnel dans le coma il a
vu leur art dans l'ordinaire et c'est
annie pensant toujours qu'on trouve ce
rare dans l'ordinaire et je voudrais
revenir à ces mots en isme l'a7
des bruits dépassé la mode de ce n'est
pas seulement vivre dans l'intemporel
comme ce n'est pas ça la mode c'est
toujours la même forme
il ne faut pas croire qu'ils à la mode
du 19e ou la mode maintenant il ya une
seule mode qui est la suivante on a
parlé tout à l'heure des écoles qui se
battaient ensemble c'est ça la vraie
mode et c'est de ça que je crois que
l'inventeur s'est retiré généralement
dans l'invention à la petite semaine
c'est-à-dire dans l'air du temps on
avait du temps et il s'agit simplement
de faire passer un pion d'un point à un
autre de mm et ça ça se fait à
l'intérieur du rapport de force entre
les groupes de pression alors on bouge
un rouge un petit peu mais c'est à
l'intérieur de la bagarre entre les
groupes de pression bojan donc on
justifie justifie sa place voilà et sa
chanson l'argent et c'est ça ça c'est
resté dans la mode est dans l'air du
temps
en fait la plus grosse difficulté dans
la méthodologie de l'invention c'est à
dire si on veut réellement inventé c'est
d'essayer d'être indépendant de cette
lutte et de cette bagarre c'est pourquoi
les grands inventeurs et l'histoire un
petit peu romantique des grands
inventeurs nous les présente comme des
solitaires comme des misérables comme
des gens oubliés comme des gens qui ont
pu général mais du dico son c'est vrai
mais au fond c'est vrai c'est à dire ce
pour quoi ils sont misérables oublier
etc
c'est parce qu'il ne participait pas à
la bataille entre les groupes de
pression il ne participe pas à la
bataille entre les parties parce qu'il
ya des partis autant dans les sciences
que dans la politique est en connaît
dans les parties au nez dans l'opinion
on est dans la croyance on est stable on
étend le cac et on ne bouge pas on est
immobile on est au chaud oui on est au
chaud c'est tout à fait confortable mais
l'invention c'est sortir de ce genre de
vie sortir de ce genre d'action
s'exposer c'est ça or pour s'exposer il
n'y a qu'une solution c'est poser les
armes poser des armes c'est l'acte même
d'un an
non la condition d'une avance ainsi sa
rue dès le moment où on est à
l'extérieur de ce genre de choses alors
on peut penser le pour tout quoi j'ai
dit tout à l'heure
la science permet de penser n'importe
quoi à l'internât certains types de
contraintes et bien pour penser ce
n'importe quoi c'est à dire pour pouvoir
être libre de penser il faut je crois
évitez tout à fait ce type de querelles
alors on dit toujours que pour inventer
il faut des polémiques des grèves c'est
le contraire qui est vrai la polémique
la querelle c'est toujours l'air du
temps
l'opinion la croyance c'est toujours la
polémique l'invention fédéral ce sont
des petits pas c'est des petits pas qui
pouvait être prévu c'est cette fois
c'est à dire d'un dans la bataille entre
deux groupes
on peut prévoir à quel endroit ils
placeront leur d où ils placeront leurs
pions sur un échiquier déjà la une à
truites nous n'en ayons tout ça tu
définis très bien les conditions de la
vente fixé les conditions de version tu
ne dis rien de l'invention est le même
tu dis qu'on peut trouver n'importe quoi
je ne dis pas par quel miracle il se
fait qu'on trouve quelque chose alors
ceci serait tout à fait en dehors du
dessin car inventé c'est précisément
n'avoir pas de méthode ou trouver une
méthode qui n'est pas descriptible par
mois ce moment en ce moment il ya
quelqu'un qui invente une idée nouvelle
et si elle est nouvelle je ne peux pas
la décrire puisqu'elle est nouvelle par
conséquent on ne peut pas parler de
l'invention ya pas de guide michelin
pour aller dans un entretien à tel mais
est-ce qu'il est vrai au point où tu as
l'air de le suggérer qu'on ne puisse
rien dire de l'invention
on peut dire de l'invention premièrement
son histoire raconter des histoires
newton disait qu' on peut dire donc son
histoire et deuxièmement on peut essayer
de trouver ces conditions et c'est des
conditions dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
par exemple on raconte que diogène
philosophe avait tout à fait oublié
avait tout laissé
ils étaient dans la rue il était tout nu
il ne mangeait quand même le sol qu'il
était dans un tonneau qui lui servait de
niche et qu'un jour il voit passer
alexandre et alexandre lui dit qu'est ce
que tu veux que je te donne réponse que
tu te sortent de mon soleil ça veut dire
une chose très simple ça veut dire
à supposer qu alexandre me cache le
soleil il y as devant moi la force le
pouvoir
la concurrence la hiérarchie le roi si
je l'enlève l'objet c'est le soleil et
j'invente voilà la vraie leçon de
l'histoire de diogène qui n'est pas du
tout une histoire
concernant alexandre qui est une
histoire parfaitement simple qui
consiste à dire si j'écarte deux mois
tout ce qui symbolise le pouvoir à la
concurrence alors devant moi le soleil
est au fond l'inventeur c'est celui qui
regarde leur art dans l'exceptionnel
c'est-à-dire qui dans un objet
quelconque avec le soleil c'est à dire
fond la question que je voulais te poser
pour finir n'a pas de sens
la question était est ce qu'il ya des
époques plus propices que d'autres
huiles invention oui parce que y'a comme
un oui c'est un sens parce qu'il ya
quand même des périodes où la liberté de
penser comme on dit est très largement
répandu et où il est plus facile pour
les hommes pour ceux qui travaillent
il est plus facile de trouver le point
de liberté que j'ai défini tout à
l'heure il ya des périodes au contraire
très serré socialement et très sûrs pour
la gloire et les genres d'époque sommes
je crois que dans une période qui ne
favorise pas la mention parce que
précisément non seulement dans les
matières politique mais à l'intérieur
même de la science
la lutte entre les groupes est très très
sévère
si lausanne abstraire alors que c'est un
héros qui peut s'abstraire de ça quelles
seraient les conditions d'un peu de deux
dénouements de sade un peu de
relâchement
ce tissu trop serré le moins
d'organisation possible ah c'est tout à
fait le contraire de tout ce qui est dit
mais c'est à dire moins 7 organisé -
s'est administré plus invente en fait la
science ça coûterait pas cher si elle
était attentive mais elle dit toujours
qu'elle manque d'argent
oui mais elles s'organisent beaucoup
elle l est les eps sinistre énormément
et c'est très cher en fait je crois que
si on ne financer que l'invention ça
serait assez pour marcher je vois la
liberté toujours très bon marché
[Musique]